official Marvel phase three is here so
what the heck does that mean well for
one it means that many of your favorite
characters are about to take a dirt nap
here's a look at some of the huge
characters that will probably die in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe phase three
number one Captain America now no
spoilers but in the comic Captain
America's Civil War is based on Captain
America gets killed oh wait did we say
no spoilers sorry but that's not the
only reason why we don't expect Captain
make it out of phase three alive while
star Chris Evans has spoken publicly
about his desire to continue working
with Marvel he's also been forthright
about when to work behind the camera
instead of in front of it
Evans might be around for phase four all
right he's just more likely to be
directing Stan Sebastian as the new
Captain America
rest in peace Steve Rogers number two
Thor if there's one thing we learn from
studying norse mythology it's that
Ragnarok is very very bad after all it
involves the destruction and death of
all the gods
so expecting Thor to survive the events
of Thor Ragnarok is beyond optimistic
there is some hope though in the comics
Ragnarok is an endlessly repeating cycle
of death and rebirth
so it's possible Thor could be reborn
but he'll have to die first for that to
happen so don't be surprised when old
Goldilocks takes a permanent arrow to
the knee or gets reincarnated as a woman
which I would be totally cool with
number three
Thanos at this point big cosmic daddy
fan OHS has almost had more cameos than
Stanley but in the two-part Avengers
infinity war Thanos is finally going to
get the spotlight and it's going to be a
bloody one Thanos after all worships
death so even when he inevitably loses
he still gets what he really wants most
in the end the question isn't whether
Thanos will die it's how many heroes
he'll take down with him speaking of
which number four Ironman of all the
stars powering the Marvel Cinematic
Universe none is as important as Robert
Downey jr. and none have been quite so
upfront as downey about being tired of
putting on the costume again so it
shouldn't come as a surprise to anyone
if Ironman makes the ultimate sacrifice
in Avengers infinity war especially
given the clear foreshadowing of exactly
that and Tony Stark's dream sequence
from Avengers age of Ultron at least
it's probably gonna be epic number five
the
Tony Stark is just one of many heroes
were expecting to meet there and an
Avengers Infinity Ward chances are that
the vision is going to join him in
perpetual rest why
well the synthetic man who stole ever
seen an Avengers age of Ultron was given
life by the Infinity stone he wears on
his brow and fan oasiz going to need
that stone in order to complete the
Infinity Gauntlet hopefully someone will
be able to rebuild vision after Thanos
dismantle Semak number six Drax the
destroyer Drax the destroyer x' entire
reason for living is to exact vengeance
on the villains who killed his family
and that means panis it's inevitable
that Drax is going to get a showdown
with Thanos at some point but given the
relative power levels it's also
inevitable that Drax is going to come
out on the losing end don't be sad
though when you think about it
is there really any other way the
single-minded Drax could go out number
seven Gamora Drax isn't the only member
of the guardians of the galaxy who has a
grudge to settle with Thanos
his adopted daughter Gamora is also one
of many looking to permanently wipe that
giant grin off of Thanos his ugly mug
given that he trained her to be the
universe's deadliest assassin she has a
better chance than most but like Drax
Gamora has one big thing going against
her odds for survival in the comics they
were both killed by Thanos hey it ain't
easy being green and a number eight
everyone if it sounds like pretty much
everyone you care about is going to die
that's because they are in the comic
book Infinity Gauntlet which all the
cosmic stuff in the Marvel movies is
based on Thanos actually wins and kills
everyone don't be surprised if that's
the cliffhanger ending to Avengers
infinity War part 1 of course eventually
panis is defeated anyway and most of the
heroes are resurrected so don't worry
the Marvel Cinematic Universe will
survive whether he'll survive the stress
of the viewing experience though is
another question entirely
thanks for watching don't forget to Like
and subscribe if you want more